à Besançon elle faisait quasiment partie
du patrimoine jusqu'en 2017 les dragées
Jacquemin étaient sur toutes les tables
des baptêmes mariages ou communion
aujourd'hui rue deskras lieu de la
dernière activité ne reste que des
souvenirs
ça fait tout de suite penser à dragées
il y a beaucoup de gens qui encore
aujourd'hui qui connaissent les dragées
Jacques main tous les francs-contaux
venaient acheter des dragées dans le
magasin d'usine de préférence bien sûr
elles étaient en vente aussi chez les
détaillants mais lors des grands
mariages ou des grands baptêmes ou des
grandes communions dans le Haut-Doubs
les gens se déplaçaient pour venir
acheter cette dragée qui était d'une
qualité exceptionnelle l'histoire
démarre avec l'arrière-grand-père
Jacquemin qui crée en 1854 sa fabrique
de dragées au 38 grande rue avant de la
déplacer rue des Granges
c'est lui qui fabriquait lui-même ses
dragées qui les vendait qu'il est livré
etc alors il avait des ce qu'on appelait
des branlantes c'est à dire c'était des
cuves en cuivre plate qui était suspendu
au plafond et donc il c'est là qu'il
secouait c'est dragées qui faisait ses
mélanges avec le siroprix etc l'affaire
est florissante et son créateur
visionnaire Jules décide alors de faire
aussi du chocolat et des bonbons c'est à
cette époque qu'il construit son usine
d'échapperets rue du Château rose
Jules Jacquemin le créateur donc de
cette entreprise va acheter le bâtiment
qui est là au coin de la rue Belfort il
va chez en même temps tous les terrains
qui montent jusque à la rue de rotonde
c'est vous dire l'importance de
l'entreprise est l'importance de cette
entreprise moderne avec
usine à vapeur comme l'on disait à
l'époque
l'usine tournera jusqu'en 1982 puis elle
sera installée rue des cras tous les
moules à chocolat ne seront plus que des
objets souvenirs seuls les dragées ils
seront encore fabriqués jusqu'à la vente
de l'entreprise aujourd'hui disparu